2021 was not a fresh start a sampling of
newspapers is front pages a stroll
through single digit cable channels a
scroll through your trusted news sites
all advance the same sentiment a new
year doesn't mean a new world a fresh
fourth digit doesn't refresh the
headlines rather 2021 was a year of news
stories evolving of headlines maturing
pandemic stories went from panic and
uncertainty over the virus to panic and
uncertainty over the vaccine and its
rollout stories on paper product
shortages turned into headlines
outlining outright supply chain chaos
coverage of police violence racial
injustice and subsequent protests move
from the streets and into the courtroom
the strongest point of continuity from
last year to this year however was that
a host of stories burned so bright that
they left little oxygen for smaller ones
to breathe so we did it again we
assembled a list of news stories one for
each country that you likely missed in
2021 some rules are the same from last
year we're not covering the big stories
you won't hear about america ending its
longest war the traffic jam in the suez
canal and you certainly won't hear me
utter the all-consuming c word in its
absence you'll notice that two other c
words came to dominate our headlines
climate change and coup d'etat these
themes point to the change in this
year's video rather than focusing on
finding stories distant from the c word
this edition's headlines reflect the
experience of each country's general
populace stories that often revolve
around responses to a rapidly changing
world and unnervingly unstable
governments the stories aren't all dark
though 2021 was tough but it was one
filled with the heartening and of course
the quirky not only does this people
first focus and form the stories we
chose but also how we organize the
stories themselves rather than going
from most populous to least like last
year we're using the human development
index or hdi hdi is a metric aimed to
quantify standard of living ranking each
country between zero and one based on
three dimensions a long and happy life
accumulation of education and earnings
the united nations compiles this list
using an algorithm that includes
indicators such as life expectancy at
birth gross national income per capita
and mean years of schooling for adults
25 and over hdi was created to as the un
states quote emphasize that people and
their capabilities should be the
ultimate criteria for assessing the
development of a country not economic
growth alone put simply hdi is the best
metric available to frame this trip
around the globe from the perspective of
everyday people but not all of the 196
unrecognized countries and territories
we cover have an hdi score missing
statistics in per capita income life
expectancy or years of education means
that seven countries didn't have a score
but they did make news so we'll start
there and then go from lowest hdi to
highest we've spent a lot of time
explaining but you're here for the
headlines so let's get started with the
first 98. we start this year in the
country that the hgi calculators
probably know the least about north
korea the hermit kingdom countered its
natural disposition when it decided to
reopen lines of communication with south
korea via the hotline that directly
connects seoul and pyongyang the
hotlines existed in one form or another
since the 1970s but has been severed
twice in the past two years on account
of the failed trump summit with the
north and joint military exercises
between the u.s and the south from
nations we'd like to know more about to
continents that spark curiosity venturi
an innovative auto company and formerly
e team from monaco announced its plan to
launch its electric polar exploration
vehicle in antarctica while the world's
been sending vehicles down there for
decades venturis will be the first that
spews zero admissions as it transports
scientists across the continent to
conduct important climate change
research while it's been tested on
french ski resource the sole focus has
been getting the vehicle ready for the
southern continent a mission laid bare
by the vehicle's name antarctica the
news out of naru suggested that 2021
wasn't one to critically rethink its
international agreements but a chance to
double down at least that was the case
when the country renewed its deal with
australia to serve as an offshore
processing location for asylum seekers
looking to enter the popular migration
destination while the extension keeps
the island nation in the good graces of
regional power broker australia it keeps
the island connected to and complicit in
an asylum system that many including the
un has decried as cruel and inhuman with
its delays decrepit living conditions
and reports of abuse 2021 was an
olympics year and one of the smallest
countries in the world took two podiums
san marino a 23 square mile 60 square
kilometer enclave surrounded by italy
earned its first olympic medal women's
trap shooter alessandra pirelli took
home a bronze during the summer games
but it wasn't just her award now the
country with 33 000 people came in first
for being the least populated territory
in the world to earn an olympic medal
surpassing bermuda's 70 thousand smalia
got its first taste of the silver screen
in 30 years when the national theater of
somalia reopened for screening featuring
two short films by a homegrown director
the theater closed in 1991 at the start
of the country civil war has been used
frequently by warlords as their
headquarters and was then bombed by
anti-entertainment jihadists its
reopening though tenuous and under heavy
security marked a flicker of hope for
civilians especially the flake loving
ones and we're not even into the list
but we're already at climate change
tuvalu's foreign minister went viral for
addressing the cop 26 climate summit
knee deep in water a strong image that
demonstrates the peril facing the island
nation which only rises to 15 feet or
four and a half meters above sea level
he's asking that if the nation goes
underwater it can retain ownership to
its maritime zones and rights as a state
even if residents have to relocate
existential questions for a very
non-existential crisis
in a less systemic and more personal
response to climbing temperatures the
vatican's most famous residents donated
15 000 ice creams to local prisoners
during an unpleasant hot snap in a
summer that set heat records across the
italian peninsula while the gesture was
admittedly minor it signaled the
vatican's dedication to aid the local
population down on its luck the
vatican's charity office has also
provided free testing and vaccines
during the pandemic and has taken locals
experiencing homelessness out for pizza
in what's been a tough year for a myriad
of reasons niger made history with its
first ever peaceful democratic
transition of power when president
mahamadu isofu relinquished the position
after two terms the limit outlined in
the country's constitution niger elected
and placed its new president muhammad
bazoom while claims of fraud protest
outright violence and a stymied coup
nearly derailed it 2021's successful
transition of power was the country's
first since it gained independence in
1960.
just as niger elected its new leader the
central african republic lost one of
their own heavily criticized for the
government's inability to foster peace
among ethnic groups its worrying ties
with russia and its bungled relationship
with france who have now pulled their
military aid out of the country furman
nirbata announced that he and his
government had handed over their
resignation on twitter
just north in chad 2021 saw both the
suspension and reinstatement of the
judean football organization by the
hands of fifa citing government
interference in chad's effort to seize
the association's authority and training
grounds an unsurprising overstep under
the ruling military council soccer's
ruling body banned the country from
international tournaments while
restrictions were ultimately lifted chad
was disqualified from the all-important
2021 africa cup of nations the world's
youngest country south sudan rang in its
10th anniversary with a first as the
mobile provider digital launched in the
capital city of juba digital is the
first south sudanese owned and operated
mobile network and its stated goal is to
roll out 4g and juba at competitive
rates and provide mobile service for
remote areas a meaningful step in the
country's development
important infrastructure developments
might be afoot in nearby burundi as well
in july the heads of state from burundi
and the democratic republic of the congo
signed cooperative agreements aimed to
foster trade stamp out rebels and
literally bridge the russia river-sized
gap between the neighboring countries
expanding rail lines and electrification
along the borderlands are also key
components of the agreements these deals
signal on paper when its leaders claim
have always connected the two countries
in their words a historic brotherhood
non-uplets is the crossword worthy term
that reached household level parlance
across mali in 2021 backed by nationwide
well wishes 21 year old halima sise was
sent to a specialist in morocco in late
march to deliver seven babies or so she
thought to her doctor's surprise sise
harbored nine all of which were born in
good health sise's nun uplets now mark
the record for the most babies born at
once
as the world warms cities are getting
hot sometimes deadly hot this is the
case in freetown the capital city of
sierra leone in the face of deadly heat
waves the city has appointed an extreme
heat official to draft a comprehensive
heat strategy raise general awareness
and create ways to protect the city's
most exposed freetown's extreme heat
official is not just the first in africa
but only the third such official in the
world joining those recently appointed
in miami and athens
inspiration takes many forms for bikini
faso nationals it took the form of the
massive smiling iron bibby who set a new
world record in log lifting while
western media might have overlooked his
504 pound over the head lift in glasgow
scotland his triumph was big news in
burkina faso as residents welcomed him
back at the airport in droves the moment
wasn't lost on iron bibby who dedicated
his trophy to his home country as quote
a message of hope
on the other side of africa in
mozambique researchers have found that
elephants have begun ditching their
tusks in the name of survival once rare
tuskless african elephants have become
increasingly common over the past 50
years largely on account of poachers
with 90 of the country's elephants
killed for their ivory during
mozambique's civil war tuskless
elephants benefited from an increased
opportunity to pass down their tuskless
genes with poaching down and
conservation up in recent decades though
it's expected that tusks will come back
in vogue
if you're looking for a reminder that
the past is very much part of the
present look no further than eritrea
over 300 eritreans born during italy's
rule have demanded italian citizenship
in the seven odd decades since colonial
rule eritrean claims to italian
citizenship based on paternal bloodlines
have fallen on deaf ears racial rules
during the fascist period current
italian immigration policy lack of
documentation and limited mobility under
eritrea's dictatorial rule have kept an
estimated thousands of eritreans from
accessing italian citizenship the latest
push for recognition though shows these
claims aren't fading quietly elegant
meticulously groomed and arranged trees
and bushes aren't likely what one would
expect along the war-torn streets of
yemen but that's what you'll run into
when passing through the city of marib
where trees sculpted into shapes figures
and animals lying roadways in a region
of critical strategic importance
representing one of the government's
last surviving strongholds this city
beautification project begun in 2016 has
offered a welcome respite from the
country's dragging civil war
dragging also describes the legacy of
the west african ebola outbreak as the
repercussions of the epidemic that ended
in 2016 may still be taking shape
researchers suspect that this year's
ebola outbreak of 20-plus probable cases
in guinea was triggered by a survivor of
the earlier outbreak while scientists
knew that in the rarest of cases the
virus could shed and transmit up to 500
days after infection the finding that a
body harbored the virus for a full five
years was a surprising and frightening
development
fifty thousand dollars still goes a long
way in liberia fifty thousand dollars
and doing the right thing with it will
earn you a chance to meet the president
that was the case for emanuel tulo a
teenage motorcycle taxi driver who found
a plastic bag on the side of the road
stuffed with 50 grand in cash and
returned it in full to the businesswoman
who had lost it his good deed was
praised by liberians and earned him the
chance to meet the president with whom
he wanted to discuss getting himself and
fellow youngsters back in school
for the first time
male green sea turtles off the coast of
guinea-bissau are getting gps tags to
better understand the endangered species
travel and feeding patterns not only is
the attention a boon for the in trouble
turtles it signals the growing trust
between outside researchers and
notoriously protective island residents
who have successfully defended and
worshipped this sacred environment for
centuries
researchers have treaded lightly and in
turn benefited mightily from shared
local knowledge and expertise to cash
and tag the ranging reptiles
finding a middle ground built on trust
and respect has also shaped an important
development in the democratic republic
of the congo has called for the
repatriation of artifacts by activists
and officials made headway in 2021 in
the wake of the global black lives
matter movement the belgian government
released their plan to return all
illegitimately procured african
artifacts most of which were stolen from
the congo this plan marks the first
systematic government-led effort to
return objects stolen during the
country's violent colonization on the
continent
across several malawian cities
protesters took to the street bonded by
the same plight data prices are too darn
high it seems a fair frustration as one
gigabyte costs nearly 28
making it the third most expensive rate
of all unrecognized countries malawi
regulators have expressed their concern
over exorbitant rates as the prices
threaten to slow social economic
development the stories of two prominent
headline makers collided this year when
tedros adhanam director general of the
world health organization spoke on the
dire situation in north ethiopia in
november the director general said that
the tigray region of ethiopia was under
a quote systematic blockade and that
people were dying because of the lack of
supplies he also noted that tegrans were
being arrested on mass
from tigre himself adhanam never
directly assigned blame as he's worked
diligently to maintain a neutral
position on the civil war that has
consumed his home country as part of
their seemingly odd and certainly
confusing court case against myanmar the
gambia won an important ruling this year
on behalf of the rohingya a muslim
ethnic group persecuted in myanmar the
tiny gambia with the backing of the
organization of islamic cooperation a
group of 57 nation states filed a
lawsuit against myanmar in 2019. in
september of this year a judge ordered
facebook to disclose account records
pertaining to the persecution in myanmar
a big win for the gambia as it's widely
understood that social media played a
key role in the 2017 genocide sudan's
progress towards democratic rule hit a
major speed bump this october when the
military seized power since the ousting
of omar al-bashir in 2019 sudan has been
trending in the democratic direction
that is until this most recent coup in
response to the backslide thousands of
protesters hit the streets in khartoum
while the u.s suspended a 700 million
dollar aid package meant to aid in the
transition towards civilian governance
the story is still developing though as
the u.s and u.n are pressuring the
military to release imprisoned
politicians and return a civilian
government to power democracy is in
trouble in haiti too after a deadly
earthquake a presidential assassination
and bout after bout of gang violence
chaos and uncertainty are primed to
carry into 2022 as general elections
have been postponed for the fourth time
this postponement comes after the prime
minister decided to dissolve the council
responsible for organizing elections the
pm has said he plans on naming a new
council but is not committed to a
timeline a move that leaves the
spiraling states well spiraling 130
young female footballers and their
families from afghanistan can finally
take a deep breath
four months after fleeing kabul as the
taliban closed in and after stops in
portugal and pakistan the afghan
athletes arrived in london via chartered
flight their escape was made possible by
a litany of ngos and philanthropists one
of which was the chairman of leeds
united the club where the girls will
join the youth team ranks
2021 was a big year for african
astronomy especially for the senegalese
scientist maram kerry as the
international astronomical union
retitled the less than personable
asteroid 35462 to maram carry no spaces
not only making the asteroid hurling
between mars and jupiter more
approachable the renaming serves as a
recognition of the life's work of the
director of africa space and founding
member of the african astronomical
society while also shining a light on
the nation's science ambitions
senegal doesn't hold a monopoly on
western african ambition though
bureaucrats in togo took the difficult
task of distributing pandemic-related
relief funds head-on this year by
developing a remarkably efficient
digital payout platform with only spotty
census data and flawed tax records
officials creatively leverage voter
registration to verify applicants before
paying out the aid over sms a program
that makes the us's look antiquated by
comparison the violence that's gripped
ethiopia for the past year has done no
favors for east african neighbors either
see the tiny coastal nation of djibouti
in july protesters responding to a
state-led attack blocked the rail line
that connects the landlocked ethiopia to
the ocean djibouti's port through which
a whopping 90 of all ethiopian goods
pass is the country's key economic
driver and while the rail line's closure
wasn't permanent instability in ethiopia
has hampered the reliant djibouti
economy to the tune of an estimated 1.7
billion dollars in lost commerce
it's been a tough few years for the ski
industry and lesotho's afroski mountain
resort proved that while unique in terms
of its status as one of two resorts in
southern africa it wasn't an exception
to the struggles rather than go under
when south african border closures led
to a 90 drop in visitors the resort
adapted this year offering incentives
and reduced rates to get locals on the
hill some for the very first time while
also finding creative renovation
projects to keep its local staff
employed chameleons by their very nature
are hard to spot a chameleon measuring
just 29 millimeters from tip to tail
nearly impossible and yet a group of
scientists in northern madagascar
discovered a pair of these
nano-chameleons who are now in the
record books as the smallest of the
planet's 11 500 reptiles like so much in
madagascar though the future of the
little lizard is up in the air as
habitat loss has conservationists
scrambling to protect the new finding
from new findings to expensive and rare
findings petra diamonds the british
producer of pink diamonds donned by the
queen herself has settled to pay 4.3
million pounds to 71 tanzanian claimants
who've accused the mining company of
among other things beating stabbing and
detaining them during their time as
miners while the settlement makes quote
no admission of liability petra has
vowed to fund community projects and
prevent future incidents in the ivory
coast stamping out illegal cocoa grow
operations has proved next to impossible
but that could change with the adoption
of the most recent european commission's
plan to curb global deforestation if
implemented this plan would require
companies importing cocoa products into
the eu to provide gps data on the
product's origin to ensure it wasn't
illegally harvested for the ivory coast
spreading the responsibility of halting
illegal cocoa production will help
protect the meager 15 of its biodiverse
forest still standing it's been 15 years
since shell's nigerian subsidiaries
pipelines poisoned the farmlands of the
villages of [ __ ] and aruma and 13 years
since the case went to court but this
year a dutch court finally ruled that
royal dutch shell and its nigerian
subsidiary must compensate the villages
for a still undecided amount and install
warning systems along its pipelines to
curb the next disaster
in rwanda the crackdown on dissonance
under president paul kagame's government
has extended to youtube creators judan
and yonsenga whose channel ishima tv
covers topics such as human rights
abuses and has over 15 million views was
sentenced to seven years in prison after
being found guilty of forgery
humiliation of state officials and two
other charges he was the second rwandan
youtube critic to be arrested in a
country where freedom of expression is
becoming increasingly costly expressing
dissent with uganda's 900-mile 1500
kilometer oil pipeline project is
becoming costly too citing lack of
compensation for land and a host of
environmental dangers local activists
and international ngos are raising
concerns over the project that begins in
murchison national park and borders lake
victoria it seems they're fighting an
uphill battle against the project which
is backed by tanzania uganda and
companies from france and china as
uganda has arrested six protesters a
move some see as a scare tactic
elsewhere on the continent people's
voices are getting through in benin a
law passed that drastically expands
access to abortion and largely puts the
decision in women's hands what used to
be legal only in cases of
life-threatening pregnancies rape and
incestuous relationships is now allowed
on account of a wide range of reasons
within the first 12 weeks of pregnancy
globally this move has been hailed by
women's rights activists and regionally
this makes benin the most progressive
country on the issue in west africa in a
country that's 90 sahara with only one
permanent river water's hard to come by
facing shortages and inconsistent supply
mauritania recently launched a
fundraising effort to secure 317 million
dollars for a project that will provide
water to half a million in the south of
the arid country counting on several
financiers from across the arab world
the project will pipe water to urban and
rural users in a bid to minimize the gap
between the two and help to realize the
region's agricultural potential from a
country with limited water to one with
little land it's been a momentous year
for sports fans on the island of comoros
as the nation of under a million was
ground zero for a history making run by
the national soccer team minnows on the
continental level comoros held world cup
qualifiers egypt to a draw and went
unbeaten during the african cup league
of nations qualifying stage a cinderella
run that will see the nation make the
cup tournament for the first time not
bad for a team that didn't even exist
until 2006.
as team caesars we don't condone tossing
trash into the ocean but sometimes such
littering lends itself to a story
picking up plastic along the beaches of
a papua new guinean island steven amos
stumbled across a message in the bottle
that had traveled 1500 miles or 2 400
kilometers after being tossed overboard
by an american sailor two years prior in
a nation struggling with major plastic
pollution perhaps amos smiled not only
at the friendly note but also at the
fact that it was contained in a nice
reusable glass bottle
how young is too young to charge someone
with a crime pakistan faced down this
very question when they charged an
eight-year-old of blasphemy when the
hindu child peed in an islamic school
library in the incidents wake police
charged the boy while in reaction to the
perceived disrespect a mob vandalized a
hindu temple eventually though the state
stepped in and punished the cops who
arrested the child dropped all charges
and organized payment for the temple's
repairs
charges that are sticking however
relayed against two transgender women
who were simply having dinner in
cameroon when they were arrested for
alleged homosexuality later they were
sentenced to five years in jail which
some say is a death sentence in the male
dominated prison system the arrest and
high-profile nature of the case as one
of the women is an activist for trans
rights exemplifies the anti-lgbtq
sentiments and laws that are still
common in african countries with at
least 30 of them criminalizing
homosexuality technology seems to be a
storyline and this is clearly the case
for isis-affiliated women held at the
all hall refugee camp in syria where
they are marrying men they meet online
in order to receive income and the slim
chance of eventual repatriation the camp
which is home to nearly 60 000 women and
children is teeming with squalor and
extremist ideas yet jihadist men
reportedly see it as a badge of honor to
care for the women there through these
virtual marriages even though they
rarely move beyond anything but digital
for something much more tangible a
solomon islands man digging in his
backyard to install a septic system
struck something hard but this was the
opposite of treasure instead he
discovered more than 100 unexploded
world war ii bombs which came as a real
surprise and a tragic reminder of the
devastation the pacific islands suffered
during that era when thousands of bombs
were dropped and munition stores like
this one were common the ordinances were
successfully and thankfully removed by a
specialist team
in the opposite of underground zimbabwe
plans to launch its first satellite the
zimsat-1 in february it will be used to
help organizations and officials collect
data that relates to ground cover and
drought as well as transmit signals for
amateur radio stations zimbabwe space
program has grown quickly in just three
years since being established and
follows on the heels of other african
countries extending upward as well
though many countries focus on the
pressing humanitarian needs first the
continent satellite fleet now stands at
44 as they increasingly recognize the
importance of strategic space investment
break out those dancing shoes because
the rumba may officially be a part of
worldwide intangible cultural heritage
the republic of the congo and the
democratic republic of the congo applied
to unesco for the official designation
which would protect the dance's history
and cement its importance the rumble was
born in 19th century cuba combining the
drumming of enslaved africans with the
melodies of spanish colonizers but it's
not just of historical importance
because the rumba has modern day
relevance too including the 1960s
independence cha-cha a version of the
rumba that celebrated the freedom of
belgian congo
in the same region downstream effects
from an angolan diamond mine were
catastrophically felt in a toxic spill
that sickened more than 1 million people
killed 12 and decimated fish and
wildlife waste from the largest diamond
mine in angola leaked into the kazai
river which eventually reached the congo
river where large amounts of heavy metal
were detected the mine which is
partially owned by a russian company
acknowledged there had been a leak but
said that it was just sand and mud and
of course they claimed no responsibility
for the disaster there's no
accountability in this story either but
there is a bit of good news from a
country that's increasingly cracking
down on the freedom of the press myanmar
released american journalist danny
fenster from prison just days after he
was sentenced to 11 years for charges
that included incitement of violence and
visa violations the military in myanmar
has clamped down on the media since
seizing power in february stripping
publications of their licenses and
banning outlets from broadcasting
fenster however was the first foreign
journalist to be convicted for charges
he says were without warrant and thanks
to negotiations by a former u.s
ambassador to the u.n now he'll go free
imprisonment in an authoritarian country
is one person's nightmare while 10
million fruit bats descending on a
condensed swamp area might sound like
another's but for conservationists in
zambia is essential the bats are key to
african ecology because they eat fruits
and berries and distribute the seeds
during their continental migration now
these environmentalists are fighting a
proposal for a 17 and a half thousand
acre or seven thousand hectare wheat soy
and corn farm that would be built on the
national park's borders and threatened
the bat's habitat and existence
altogether
in another story about west african
instability guinea hunter leader mamadi
dumbuya was sworn in after a successful
september coup marking the fourth coup
in the region in the past year dumboya's
party overthrew former president alpha
khande for what they said was continued
corruption but political upheaval
continues to mire the area and now
regional economic council has placed
economic sanctions and travel
restrictions on the canaan junta
sometimes government overreach isn't
always so unpleasant as is the case with
a defend and declawed lion named hima he
was reunited with his owner after the
cambodian prime minister got involved
initially himmo was seized after
tick-tock videos of him living casually
in a high-end phenom pen neighborhood
something the government deemed
inappropriate went viral but additional
posts showed a clear bond between the
two after their separation and following
public calls for reunification the prime
minister announced the two would be
rejoined
speaking of lions kenya is known as a
wildlife wonderland but just how many
creatures crawl there was an unknown
number until the country completed its
first wildlife census this year using
planes drones helicopters boats and four
by fours researchers tally the
populations of more than 30 species
across nearly 60 percent of the country
to establish a baseline for one of the
world's most unique ecological places
using estimates from the past the
numbers of elephants some 36 280 seem to
be going up but black rhinos just 897
have fallen to critically endangered
levels
kenya counts wildlife and nepal counts
how many people reach the top of mount
everest
now they're unhappy with three indian
climbers who allegedly falsified their
summit of the world's highest peak in
2016. this year the nepalese government
penalized them by banning them for six
years essentially preventing them from
actually trying to get to the top
another time the nepalese ministry
verifies climes through photographic
evidence and while these three have the
photos presumably photoshopped they
reportedly didn't have enough oxygen to
have feasibly completed the trip
back at sea level impoverished east
timor is at an interesting economic
crossroads exploring ecotourism offshore
drilling and now carbon capture storage
as a way to boost the country's revenue
australia has proposed capturing its own
carbon waste and paying to store it in
east timor's nearly depleted bayou unden
oil field which is expected to run out
in the next couple of years proponents
see this as a creative environmental
solution and critics say it's simply
shifting climate change responsibility
from a rich country to a poor one nearby
vanuatu is a remote pacific island which
is three hundred thousand residents so
why did some two thousand politicians
business owners and criminals get
citizenship there recently because for a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars they
can the citizenship by investment
program is legal and gives these new
residents visa-free access to the uk and
european union but some worry the
increased interest in this island where
the passport program accounted for
nearly 42 percent of government revenue
in 2020 might be fertile ground for
money laundering and international
mischief
in a move that signals the increasing
geopolitical importance of africa
twitter hired its first employees on the
continent in the country of ghana where
freedom of speech protections and online
freedoms made it an ideal location the
social media company announced it would
fill 11 positions with plans to
officially open an office there once
pandemic restrictions and work from home
orders are relaxed
for more than 30 years east suatini's
king muswati iii has ruled as an
absolute monarch and flaunted a lavish
luxurious lifestyle the problem sixty
percent of the country's 1.1 million
residents live in poverty and they're
over his opulence for months residents
have participated in pro-democracy
protests that have left scores dead and
many more wounded neighboring african
countries including south africa upon
which eastwatini heavily relies are
stepping in to help navigate the
movement which many say won't be going
away until there's a brighter future for
this developing nation a plot to smuggle
55 million methamphetamine tablets and
more than 1.5 tons of crystal meth
disguised in beer crates was thwarted by
police in laos resulting in the largest
single drug seizure in asia they were
discovered in a truck in an area called
the golden triangle the meeting point of
myanmar laos and thailand which is
notorious as a hotspot for drug
production and smuggling with recent
unrest in myanmar shawn region and
chinese crackdown on the trade smugglers
have looked to alternate routes in this
case without much success
in another superlative pacific islander
nicole yamase became the first citizen
of the federated states of micronesia to
reach challenger deep the deepest part
of the mariana trench which lies within
the territorial waters of the country
her completion of the 10 hour journey
which took her to 36 000 feet or 11 000
meters below the ocean's surface also
makes her only the third woman and at 29
the second youngest to ever do it she's
a phd student studying climate change's
effects on microalgae and going to the
world's most remote places for research
is all in a day's work for her on the
topic of climate change in an effort to
reduce its dependence on fossil fuels
sal toming and princep made an
innovative announcement involving deep
water platforms but not the oil kind
instead they're engaging in a
public-private partnership to debut
ocean thermal energy conversion
technology the first commercial endeavor
of its kind the floating platforms use
the difference between cold deep ocean
water and warm surface temperatures to
create green energy out of the blue
another island nation concerned for its
future is kiribas where six years ago
the government starred in its own
version of house hunters and purchased
some 8.5 square miles or 22 square
kilometers of land on fiji to make sure
its potentially displaced residents had
somewhere to go as sea levels rise to
use that land in the meantime kiribati
enlisted the help of omnipresent china
to build farms that would provide fresh
produce and meat to the island nation
which currently imports all of its food
some say this is another land grab by
china while others see it as a
sustainability measure for kiripos both
of these takes miss what might be the
most interesting part of this story an
actual overseas climate refuge in the
first place
garment workers in bangladesh are more
protected after an agreement was signed
by some 200 international fashion
companies that includes legally binding
safety commitments independent
inspections at the factories and
contributions for safety training and
factory improvements the accord replaces
one that was created after a devastating
factory fire that killed 1100 people in
2013 and was set to expire human rights
workers praised the move which means
protections will continue into the
future and keep bangladesh as one of the
top garment producers in the world
that pandemic coffee habit may be
helping boost honduras economy according
to recent economic reports gdp growth
for 2021 was expected to be between two
and five percent but new projections
show almost double that with the
country's economy predicted to grow by
almost nine percent this is thanks to
increased activity in retail and
manufacturing and because of supply
chain issues higher prices for coffee
which is one of the country's primary
exports if two is a party and three's a
crowd then india is taking note some
states including the country's most
populous uttar pradesh which has 240
million people and would be the world's
fifth most populous country by itself
introduced a china-like two-child policy
and sterilization measures to control
population growth though it still has to
be adopted the proposal would deny state
benefits subsidies and jobs to anyone
who has more than two children and
dangles the carrot of incentives for
anyone who gets sterilized 12 states
have already adopted similar measures
all in an effort to limit growth in a
country that's already the second most
populous in the world in the early 1900s
namibia was known as german southwest
africa and germany is still dealing with
its dark history there which included
troops that killed tortured and forced
tens of thousands of native peoples into
the desert to starve this year then
chancellor angela merkel reached a deal
that would distribute 1.1 billion euros
over 30 years to benefit aid programs in
the african country but she stopped
short of calling the funding reparations
and instead said it was reconciliation
money that would help attempt to quote
heal the wounds of the past
china continues to expand its presence
around the globe and in bhutan this
hasn't been subtle in the past year
satellite imagery shows that multiple
new villages have sprung up in a 60
square mile or 150 square kilometer
bhutanese area that's been a disputed
site before when india and china went
ahead about road construction there a
handful of years ago because of aligned
interests when it comes to chinese
overreach india has supported bhutan's
claims to the contested territory across
the world the situation in nicaragua
right now is unequivocally bad and it
wasn't much better in early 2021 when
president daniel ortega opted to shoot
for the moon even though the nation is
mired in social and economic misery
that's when he established the national
ministry for extraterrestrial space
affairs the moon and other celestial
bodies which people are calling a vanity
project its goal is to develop a space
agency that will reach the farthest
points in the universe but quite
literally hasn't gotten off the ground
when one thinks of palm oil plantations
malaysia and indonesia usually come to
mind but guatemala's emerging market
makes it the world's sixth largest
producer of palm oil however that
success of course comes at a cost more
production has led to companies grabbing
indigenous lands at an alarming rate in
response some of guatemala's indigenous
population almost 40 of the country's 17
million residents are resisting by
forcefully moving back onto the land
native baby sea turtle numbers on the
ten island nation of cape verde are
booming in a rabbit-like way the good
news is that nest numbers last year were
up to 200 000 which is 20 times the
estimates from 2015. the bad news is
that sea turtles gender is determined by
the temperature of the sand where the
eggs are laid and well the globally
warmed beach means that about 84 of baby
sea turtle hatchlings are now female
which unfortunately still keeps that
species on the endangered list when it
comes to finding fodder for central
asians geopolitical cocktail talk here's
a fun fact tajikistan's primary export
is migrant labor by september 2021 more
than 1.6 million tajiks left the country
to work in russia these migrant workers
then send billions of dollars in
remittances back home in 2019 actually
this figure accounted for more than one
quarter of tajikistan's gdp making the
ex-soviet country still very dependent
on russia anyone who invested early in
bitcoin should head straight to el
salvador where they can make it crypto
rain now that the country became the
first in the world to adopt the currency
as legal tender though some including
major lender the international monetary
fund are skeptical because the volatile
and risky nature of cryptocurrencies
others are optimistic such as
salvadorians who can dip into their
chiva wallet app and find 30 dollars of
bitcoin waiting for them in the ongoing
fight against isis officials in iraq
declared a moderate victory with the
capture of the islamic state's finance
minister sami jasim al-azuz the arrest
could provide iraq and international
allies with a treasure trove of
intelligence about the terrorist
organization that although has retreated
from daily headlines in recent years
maintains quite active and sleeper cells
throughout the middle east two residents
in guyana are not staying quiet about
protecting the planet something they
argue is a fundamental right to
humanity's sustainability the pair is
suing their country for having approved
oil exploration licenses saying it
violates the government's legal duty to
protect the right of future generations
to a healthy environment this david vs
goliath fight pits them against exxon
mobil which is eyeing a potential 8
billion gallons of oil in offshore
drilling which would make it the
company's largest extraction site in the
world there's nothing like the discovery
of 1.3 million year old stone tools to
make this point in time seem well short
archaeologists in morocco recently
discovered the artifacts in a site
associated with human ancestor homo
erectus almost doubling the previous
start date for the dawn of the stone
tool era in north africa what's
mind-boggling is that these tools aren't
even close to the oldest traces of human
ancestors which date all the way back to
more than four million years ago in
kyrgyzstan central asia's only democracy
just over one-third of the population
turned out in a snap election that put
populist politician and convicted
kidnapper sadio jeparov into power the
former soviet country sits between china
which is invested in its infrastructure
and russia to which it still has
significant loyalties including from its
newly elected president who has vowed to
remain allied with both neighbors
something that will be tough to balance
amid his own country's partially
self-inflicted political turmoil there's
some positive news about elephants
coming out of gabon where new research
shows the population of forest elephants
a cousin to the savannah dwelling
pachyderms seem to be doing better than
expected previous estimates reported
there were about 50 000 left in the
central african country but a recent
study shows that number to be closer to
95 000 thanks to strict anti-poaching
regulations and land conservation
measures athleisure wearing latte
drinking urbanites might need an extra
downward dog and a shot of espresso to
deal with their supply chain woes this
year especially with products like
lululemon and coffee coming from vietnam
where a combination of lockdowns and
factory conditions has prompted millions
of workers to leave cities and return to
their countryside homes manufacturers
are having a tough time luring them back
and that was bad news for supply chain
already in crisis an arizona man who
conducted a years-long human trafficking
ring selling babies from the marshall
islands to american parents was
sentenced to six years in prison and
forced to pay hundreds of thousands in
restitution charges the man would pay
around ten thousand dollars for pregnant
martially's women to come to the united
states and then arrange for their
newborns to be adopted by couples for
forty thousand dollars officials
estimate some 70 adoptions took place
this way taking advantage of the compact
of free association which allowed them
to travel or move to the u.s without
restriction on the subject of pregnancy
polish researchers discovered a first an
egyptian mummy with child originally
they thought the mummy mummy was a male
priest but further investigation
uncovered a small femur bone thought to
belong to a fetus about 25 to 30 weeks
old scientists call the find unique and
important to egyptology in which little
research has been done on females
in not so sweet news ben jerry's
announced it would stop selling its ice
cream in occupied palestinian
territories making a very public
corporate statement against the israeli
settlements there which are not
recognized by international law israeli
officials called the decision a quote
capitulation to anti-semitism the brand
however will still be available
throughout the internationally
recognized territory of israel which
sort of makes this ban half-baked it's
banned for poachers to remove succulents
from the desert in south africa but that
hasn't stopped it from being an
explosive problem in a country that's
home to one-third of the world's
succulent species specifically people
are harvesting conophytum which is a
genus of flowering plants that consist
of over 100 species many of which are on
the endangered list they're then sold to
hot markets including korea and china
where the plants that were once
considered low class have become popular
for being low maintenance
across the pond venezuelans have been
fleeing their country in one of the
world's largest human migrations and one
third of them head to neighboring
colombia recently colombia announced its
decision to provide temporary legal
status to more than 1.7 million migrants
who had fled there in recent years that
means the migrants can work legally for
up to 10 years a collapsed economy has
created a humanitarian crisis and
refugees in search of a better life may
find that with colombia's legal
acceptance of them last year the
president of turkmenistan erected a
gilded statue of a beloved breed of dog
the alipai this year he took it a step
further and announced a national holiday
honoring the large shepherd-like canine
this holiday included a contest for the
country's best dog and a medal given to
its top border guard dog alibi now
shares the special day with another of
turkmenistan celebrated the occult
techie horse breed both are considered
important parts of the national heritage
where herding is a traditional pastime
traditionally the transfer of power is
supposed to be peaceful and seamless in
samoa it wasn't fiama naomi mataafa
finally became the country's prime
minister in july following several
months of constitutional crisis during
which her predecessor toiletpa salele
malele gaiue refused to acknowledge her
victory the former leader had led the
country for more than two decades and
would not step down after a series of
legal battles and appeals mata afa
finally assumed control and is making
history doing it as samoa's first female
prime minister in belize officials are
both making and saving history
ecologically that is this year a
coalition of conservation organizations
banded together to save one of the
world's last pristine rainforests
preserving 367 square miles or 950
square kilometers of land from
deforestation this area is part of the
larger belize maya forest which crosses
mexico belize and guatemala it means a
biodiversity hotspot roughly the size of
florida will be saved in perpetuity
something that's not going to last
forever is filipino president rodrigo
duterte who is constitutionally barred
from seeking another six-year term ahead
of the may elections those looking to
replace him include a potpourri of
people including his daughter sarah
duterte son and namesake of the
country's former dictator ferdinand
bongbong marcos former actor and manila
mayor francisco domagoso and newly
retired boxing star manny pacquiao with
candidates expected to perform on stage
with the public judging them on their
singing and dancing abilities the pool
is certainly high on the entertainment
factor to the south the indonesian
island of biak is becoming an unexpected
player in elon musk's world that's
because indonesian president joko widodo
as part of his goal to modernize the
nation personally pitch the tech giant
on launching spacecraft from the island
that sits 70 miles or 110 kilometers
south of the equator facing displacement
the indigenous population isn't
supportive of the proposal musk has also
stayed mum on the issue but we all know
his penchant for explosive announcements
atmospheric conditions also made
headlines in bolivia where uv radiation
levels in la paz hit 21 and that's on a
scale that typically tops out at 20.
oblivion capital sits at 11 800 feet or
3 600 meters above sea level and low
levels of clouds caused by climate
change combined with a heat wave
skyrocketed numbers on the uv index the
world health organization calls an index
of 11 extreme and 10 minutes exposed at
these levels start to burn the skin at
21 people just stay inside more than
doubling the age of most of her
competitors a 46 year old gymnast
representing uzbekistan took her final
bow at the olympics in tokyo this summer
it was oksana chusovatina's 8th olympics
she won the silver medal for vault in
2008 and capped off with 11 medals won
at 17 world championships up next
spending more time with her olympic
wrestling husband and her son who at 22
is older than most olympic gymnasts in
libya there's some frightening news on
the artificial intelligence front a
report commissioned by the united
nations found that a military drone
strike used in the country's civil war
may have been carried out autonomously
allegedly militia fighters were hunted
down and attacked by a quote weapon
system that did not require data
connectivity though it's implied the
report doesn't go as far as to say the
drone acted autonomously vagueness here
is du riger as the report also doesn't
say whether anyone was injured or killed
the island nation of tonga managed to
largely avoid the global pandemic but
it's dealing with its own epidemic now
as methamphetamine use has become
pervasive and very problematic in the
country of 100 000. it's so bad that the
king made a plea to tongan parliament
asking for help with the crisis which is
accounting for 60 of admissions to
tonga's mental health wards and filling
up local prisons tonga has long been a
stop on the drug route from asia to new
zealand and australia this just means
that the drugs are increasingly stopping
instead of passing through something
else that's stopping is the piranha
river south america's second largest
river straddles paraguay argentina and
brazil and sadly it's the lowest it's
been in more than 70 years scientists
say deforestation in the amazon is to
blame as rainfall much of which emanates
from the forest itself has significantly
decreased as a result the river is ten
and a half feet or three meters lower
than normal and threatening the lives
and businesses of people who populate
more than 60 towns along its shores
also threatening was two men's plot to
unseat jordan's king abdullah a crime
for which they were sentenced to 15
years in prison they were aids to the
king's half-brother who was removed from
the line of succession in 2004 but not
to be deterred his plan using these
proxies included rallying civilian
support to oust abdullah the twist some
say all three may have been unknowingly
backed by the trump administration who
saw abdullah as an obstacle in securing
an israeli-palestinian peace treaty the
king however will remain in power and
these two will go to jail when an
immigrant commits a crime in the united
kingdom they get deported often by
airplane lately however the loads have
been light with just four people sent
back to jamaica on a recent 350
passenger airbus a350 900 flight that
evens out to about six thousand dollars
or fifty thousand pounds per person
these costs have people wondering about
the viability of such an expensive
program while others say it's critical
to get convicted criminals out of the
country
fines that will happily be sent overseas
includes two of the world's largest
diamonds unearthed this year in botswana
a 1 174 carat and 1098 carat diamond
were both discovered weeks apart in the
country's mines which are some of the
top producing in the world each diamond
is about the size of someone's hand and
they come at an important time for the
market which is trying to rebound after
the pandemic bright news for the country
and the soon to be betrothed another
unearthing took place in mongolia where
archaeologists were able to use a new
technology to look below ground and map
the ancient city of karakarum the
capital of the mongolian empire
established by genghis khan in the 1200s
using magnetic fields to determine the
footprint's layout and structural
composition the researchers determined
among other things that the city was
only at about 40 capacity likely home to
laborers and craftspeople while the
majority lived a more nomadic lifestyle
and that brings us to halfway we'll plow
through the remaining 98 entries on
friday when part 2 is released but you
don't have to wait until then or sit
through ads for that matter if you sign
up for nebula today the streaming
platform was made by creators like me
and my friends from real science medlife
crisis real life lore and more we all
wanted to focus on content and not
stress about demonetization and
algorithms so we made our own streaming
site on nebula you can watch dozens of
your favorite educational creators
normal videos early and ad free
occasional extended cuts and companion
videos and big budget nebula originals
of course we still want you all to be
able to watch our stuff easily so we're
partnering with curiositystream which
has thousands of non-fiction shows and
documentary streaming at your fingertips
and is a big fan of what we do at nebula
so when you sign up for curiositystream
at
curiositystream.comwendover you get
nebula included for free even better
news is that curiosity stream is
offering 26 off its annual plan and you
benefit curiosity stream plus nebula all
for less than 15 a year i think we all
need some good news after some of the
stories in the year and roundup so how
about you try watching curiosity
stream's original documentary about how
the groundbreaking newly launched james
webb telescope was designed and built so
to get your time and money's worth sign
up for the bundle deal by clicking the
button on screen or heading to
curiositystream.comwendover and you'll
be helping support independent creators
while you're at it